I become obsessed with the country of
Switzerland and Swiss culture and
everything Swiss and so I decided to
come to Canada I'm in the Canadian
province of Alberta and I'm surrounded
by mountains by these evergreen forests
by no and ice and winter sports and it's
just gorgeous
as someone who's recently become
obsessed with Swiss culture
I keep seeing Swiss things here and it's
like what's going on here these are the
Canadian Rockies it's like this part of
Canada it's right on the Continental
Divide which is right where these
tectonic plates are coming together so
it's this giant mountain range
[Music]
if you rewind back to 1800s this
mountain range was basically empty
people hadn't explored it it was just
here doing its thing and son of it
accessible but these mountains were on
the cusp of a revolution Canada wanted
to start to build access into these
mountains mainly with trains
[Music]
there's a huge company in particular
Canadian Pacific that was building a
giant railway across all of Canada
including this mountain range with these
railways came this dream of a future
where people could actually visit the
mountains so they built hotels really
fancy hotels
[Music]
but let me tell you it's really hard to
navigate through mountains like this
building trains and getting into the
mountains and exploring them is a
dangerous and difficult activity so you
have these early pioneers of
mountaineering in Canada who are going
and like charting these mountains going
up peaks for the first time helping the
railway build infrastructure guiding the
first tourists through these mountains
by the end of the 1800s they were
starting to explore these mountains and
then there was an accident
this renowned climber was going up this
huge peak to explore it for the first
time when he slipped and fell to his
death this was the first recorded death
from mountaineering in all of North
America where mountaineering was like a
fairly new thing and it was a big deal
it kind of shocked people and it made
them realize that if they were gonna
chart these mountains and properly
explore them they needed help from the
experts in mountaineering which were at
the time the Swiss Canada had everything
Switzerland had in terms of mountains in
fact the renowned English climber who is
the first person to summit the
Matterhorn yes the Matterhorn when he
came to the Canadian Rockies he said
that this place was quote 50
Switzerland's in one
so they had the mountains they just
didn't have the mountain expertise which
is why they brought in the Swiss so they
started hiring Swiss Mountain experts to
come teach them the ways of trains and
mountains and tourism they called these
Swiss guys sturdy picturesque fellows
man if I could just be considered a
sturdy picturesque fellow I'm not sure
there's any higher compliment I am on a
lake ice skating surrounded by stunning
mountains stunning forests this stunning
structure behind me
this is Lake Louise nestled up here in
the Rockies I can't stop looking at
these mountains they are just the Swiss
were the experts of this they had the
knowledge and they pass it on to their
Canadian brethren this chateau became
the base camp
base for a lot of this climbing
expedition education learning how to
climb learning how to navigate these
mountains learning how to access this
and over the next 50 years there wasn't
a single fatality in all of the
exploration that happened in this area
to make way for tourism and it really
left a mark on the culture here so over
the course of the 1900s the Canadian
Rockies became discovered they built
roads hotels resorts and the Canadian
Rockies once inaccessible became a major
part of the Canadian identity
and today this mountain culture has
taken on a life of its own it's now
uniquely Canadian it's expanded and
grown in really amazing ways but it's
important to remember that the Swiss
helped build it I've been reading this
book by this Canadian historian who said
that quote it was the swiss guides who
made manifest the meaning of having so
many beautiful mountains eventually a
lot of these swiss guides went home but
the swiss influence is 100% still here
you can see the influence from those
early days when those guys were here
teaching the canadians how to access
their mountain today there are 15 peaks
in the canadian rockies that were given
swiss names but it's not just the names
of mountains there is a very swiss
institution a thing that i wanted to try
for a really long time very swiss i've
never tried it and i'm going to try for
the first time tonight in canada here we
go
[Music]
this is fondue film TV if I were
speaking French but I don't speak French
materials fondue is basically a Swiss
format where you put a communal pot in
the middle of the table with a portable
stove that heats it up and you put
different kinds of cheese in that pot
and it melts it down into this like
creamy liquidy wonderful path of
goodness
and then you start dipping and it's
again this kind of communal experience
it's like hotpot but like with cheese
totally a Swiss thing like 100% like
originates in Switzerland in in Canada
fondue gets a ten out of ten must do you
must do fondue that's my new motto must
do fondue why are you making that Rufus
must do fondue open she's gone is was it
not cool
in the 1950s a constant supply of Swiss
Mountain gear started flowing into the
Canadian Rockies and that's because of
this guy John Monnett who is one of the
swiss guides who was here as a ski
instructor and he saw the need for
quality gear that was not available here
in North America at that time was only
available in Switzerland and so he
started to bring stuff back from
Switzerland high-quality climbing gear
and apparel and clothing and boots and
it really caught on as this mountain
culture was developing he saw a giant
demand for this stuff and he started a
store that store is right behind me and
today it's one of the major retailers of
sports and outdoor equipment some of
that Swiss legacy right here on vamp
Avenue
I mean that's just full-on like Swiss
architecture galore like that you don't
get more Swiss than the net okay it was
in the 1960s when a Swiss company
brought in not only chairlifts
themselves but employees who knew how to
build and operate them that helps spread
Mountain infrastructure all throughout
the Canadian Rockies so today if you go
skiing or snowboarding here you are
partaking in some of that Swiss
influence
[Music]
in the 1920s there was the Swiss
immigrant who came here he was a
mountaineer guy Sam was John just like
me my name is John he saw this mountain
behind me and he's like I'm tired of
seeing people carry up supplies to the
teahouse at the top of this mountain
there needs to be a cable car like we
have in Switzerland but no one wanted to
pay for it couldn't raise funds so he
went back to Switzerland and he got a
bunch of business people to fund this
project and before you know it this
gondola was built let's go up it and see
what it looks like you want to go up the
gondola sweetie you're heavy don't grow
up not only was this created by a Swiss
person and funded by Swiss capital but
it's also run today by Swiss
infrastructure it's a Swiss company that
actually designs and manufactures these
cable cars and this whole system it
doesn't get any more Swiss than this but
we're here in the cave
[Music]
I'm super happy that we were able to
take this trip to uh porta this is my
first time here and I had no idea what I
was missing out on the Tourism Board
travel Alberta reached out to us and
asked if we wanted to come explore this
place and he said yes they had no
influence over the videos we made they
just told us to make whatever video we
wanted based on our trip and as I
started to poke into this kind of Swiss
influence
I became insatiable fascinated and went
down many rabbit holes bought many books
bought many maps so thank you travel
Alberta for sending me down this rabbit
hole is also made a video that's more of
a Travel Guide of everything that we did
while we were here kind of a day-by-day
so you should go over and check that out
and thanks for watching Switzerland in
North America I love it
[Music]